[Music]
imagine fitting into those jeans
in the back of your closet and feeling
confident in that dress or suit
our next guest has the solution to
shrink stubborn fat
for men and women welcome back brittany
black from the jazzy wellness brittany
tell everyone camera fall tell everyone
what
what does body contouring do and how
does it work
it's a non-surgical non-invasive
treatment that reduces fat permanently
and tightens the skin i love it
non-surgical non-evasive how many
sessions
are needed do we start seeing results
so you see something on the first
session typically between two and three
inches but we've seen up to seven
up to seven inches of fat taken away
same yeah now this is the process of how
it actually works right here's what
we're looking at
so we use multiple technologies first we
liquefy the fat cells
then we use a different technology to
permanently kill them then we use a
different technology to tighten the skin
now how long does each session last
it is permanent it's permanent and what
are some of the areas that you guys
treat anywhere we do the chin
the stomach the flanks the back the legs
anywhere and then so we're looking here
at the before and after of the back and
up to seven inches off of someone now a
session like this someone with this with
the back how long are they in there for
typically about an hour per session your
first and last are a few minutes longer
so we can get these great photos and
some measurements
talking about the pain level are we
feeling any pain when we're doing this
um i've had a lot of patients fall
asleep or describe it as a hot stone
massage
so it's painless yes and something like
this someone had their stomach done can
you go back to work afterwards is there
any down time
when you're when you're done with the
treatments no down time some people come
in and do it on their lunch break even
so it's that fast and that easy and it's
for all ages anyone can come in and do
this i'm talking adults of course but
there's it's all ages
yep we have young people we have more
elderly people we have men we have women
we have everybody
and what's the most amount of sessions
you've seen someone have to get done
we're talking you said you see results
after the first session
but is someone coming in for three four
or five sessions
typically between four and six depending
on the area and what you're looking for
awesome brittany thank you so much
especially this time of year new year
people at the resolutions want to start
looking great you guys have the
solutions
exactly a little booster yes the jazzy
wellness is located at 900
south valley view boulevard suite 100
you can find them online at
thejazzywellness.com
and take advantage of this great special
deal guaranteed to lose two inches
the same day that's where the first 10
callers actually get
40 percent off the series of body
contouring call them today
702 7406
mercedes